hey what's going on it's Bill Bird it's
time for the Monday Morning podcast for
Monday Monday Monday
yada December
11th
2023 what's going on how are
you Monday
Mondays um so something to me every
other day remember that [__] song
that it song was like 50 [__] years
ago and just talking about how bummed
out you are that it's
Monday and you got to get up and you
have to go work for somebody else and
maybe you're not going after your dream
and all of that this is what really gets
me about these [__] corporate [__]
at the top of every [__] ladder in
every [__] business in this country
is you know if I was running a company
right and somebody was [__] singing
Monday Monday and they [__] hated the
J I would feel bad being like okay what
do we need to do here I'm not paying you
guys enough money do we need a pinball
machine I I don't want you guys coming
to work [__] hating your I mean if
you're just [__] lazy I mean you know
I'm not getting you you know I'm not
getting you [__] but I mean if you're
really just like not
fulfilled like the amount of [__]
people just not
fulfilled behind the eightball just
getting [__] and these people people
just don't give a [__] and just continue
to take more and more it's just it just
beyond
me was [__] driving down the street
right like we're literally to the point
where people are just spray painting
self-help on sidewalks and on [__]
walls so as you're driving you can think
of something
positive um these are the things you
know next year
when this whole Pony and dog show of
another [__] presidential election
and uh people will get all excited or
all
sad by whichever candidate wins or loses
like what are none of them are going to
talk about this [__] none of them are
going to talk about how few people own
so much and if they do they'll
immediately be called a fringe
candidate okay you know it's a company
this how you know a politician is
corporate owned is all he's going to do
is blame the other party that's all
they're going to do and
uh I don't know I don't want to bring up
any names or any of this type of [__]
people okay blue tide and red tide we
got to get on the same page here we got
to look out for each other all right you
got to stop watching CNN and [__] Fox
News their job how they make money is to
infuriate you and make it seem like the
there's there's people that live in this
country that want to destroy it right
there are they're the people that own
those
networks but it's not your neighbor it's
not your
coworker and when you look I don't give
a [__] what industry you're looking at
you should be rooting for the workers at
this point CU everybody is getting
[__] and
uh I don't know I don't know I I wish uh
I'm telling you I was thinking that [__]
the other day like the amount of power
that we would have if we were all
[__] aligned but how can you possibly
do that I mean 24-hour news networks oh
I'm going in deep
fast like not deep like smart but just
big subjects here social media I mean
they literally have [__]
robots someone was trying to tell me
that like 40% of the
commenting on Instagram is just Bots and
they're deliberately saying contrarian
[__] just to get people going because
then somebody says something else and
then somebody else that agreed with the
robot and then it's just
often it's like robot
trolls
um I don't know and all of this AI
technology is to phase all of us out
this is for the [__] people at the
top
because they're still not happy with the
all of the money that they have they
still want to make more money and they
want to be the modern day slave owners
and the slaves are not going to be human
beings anymore it's going to be
robots the ultimate slave because
they're just going to design them I
guess not to Rebel but you know what it
is they're going to miss [__] human
beings literally and figuratively so
they're going to try to make these
things as human as possible and that's
what's going to do when and and uh would
it be wild if it was just like that if
if if the all of the human race ended
like a be horror movie from the 19
[__] 30s it's just Frankenstein all
over again um anyway I hope you guys had
a good weekend hope you got along with
people I hope you let people in somebody
driving like a [__] [__] maybe
they having a bad day who gives a [__]
let him go in don't be bad him make him
even more mad he's probably got alimony
out his [__] ass you know just just
who gives a
[__] I had a [__] oh I tell I'll tell
you I that
weekend I
uh you know my my lovely daughter um we
just decorated a Christmas tree I got a
little Christmas tree for her room um
and you know what was awesome was in the
middle of it I was like you know someday
when I'm older and she's moving out or
getting married I'm going to think about
you know when she was 6 years old and we
were just sitting there decorating the
Christmas tree and how excited she was
and I made sure I was in the moment
something I don't do a lot of and
something I then if I you know just
because I did that now does that mean I
go on social media and then give you
guys a a a unasked for lecture about how
you need to live in the moment and then
I become an influencer is that how it
works
um uh anyway so she was sick and then my
wife got
it and I thought I was in the clear it
had gone away for a few days everybody
was fine and then oh dude Friday night
oh my God Friday night I was sitting on
the couch about 7:00 at night and I had
an apple or
something maybe it was like six or
something and all of a sudden I started
feeling a little queasy I'm like what
the [__] is I go maybe I don't know
maybe I didn't eat too much today and
maybe I'm a little nauseous
so I go down to sit down for
dinner and in the walk over to the table
I got way more nauseous and then I look
and it was like this fish in like a
[__] broth or
something which who's kidding who I mean
that's enough to make you puke even if
you're feeling fine so I was like all
right I pushed that away I ate a couple
pieces of garlic braid there and then I
was
like oh no and I just said Nia I need to
go upstairs and lay down she goes oh no
and I said oh yeah so I went
upstairs and you know rather than just
give into it I'm [__] German Irish I
sat there trying to fight it for like 90
minutes and then finally I couldn't
anymore and I just said to myself like
all right this is going to suck cuz this
took my kid out for 3 days it took my
wife out for two 2
days
um there's nothing you can do just
[__] ride this out right just give to
it so at right around 7 I went into the
bathroom for the first time and I'm
going to tell you something right now
from 7 p.m. to 2:00 a.m. you could have
[__] rebooted that movie
Poltergeist this stuff was coming out of
me both [__]
ends I I don't I can't even I didn't
even know I had that much like in me
like I was puking up gum that I [__]
swallowed in the fifth grade like 50
[__] years ago it just [__]
like dude when it got to the end I was
wretching so bad I was actually laughing
at how stupid I sounded cuz I knew my
wife could hear it I've never laughed
while puking but it was towards the end
but it was like puking and before I
could even like flush the toilet I'd
have to spin around and sit down I was
just like and I just was going like I
try to like remove myself from it and
just being like this is fascinating how
the body works when there's something in
it it's just like you know get it out
either [__] way and
um it was every time I was just like
that is the last like if I puke again
like I'm like an organ's going to come
out like I don't have anything [__]
and then I would just going dude I was
doing like those [__] like these
[__] and you know like when you want
to relax you just hanging on the [__]
Bowl but your whole [__] core is just
squeezing it's like it's like a [__]
python around
you oh my God and then just a [__]
fire hose coming out your ass I mean it
I'm sorry to be so graphic but dude what
is that 7 to 12 is 5 + 2 7 hours of that
I do that right 8 9 10 11 1212 yeah 7
hours 7 [__] hours of that and then
finally at at 2
a.m. you know and I was getting the
chills just [__] everything was
[__] horrible right so at 2:
a.m. I could kind of feel like there was
something a little different on the last
[__] you know puke fire hose moment
that I was just done there was just
nothing left and I was so [__]
dehydrated I was like I'm drinking a
glass of water and I don't give a [__]
if it makes me puke so I drank a glass
of water and then like [__] 5 minutes
later I don't I puked it up so quick it
was still
cold and then that was it and then I
went to
bed I finally fell asleep and I woke up
at about 8 8: in the
morning and uh my lovely wife was
getting our kids ready for school I mean
I usually get up I I make the bre oh no
I I did I went downstairs and I made a
breakfast she goes what the [__] are you
doing out of bed and I'm like I don't
know I I feel great cuz I woke up and I
had a glass it was just gone like my
body did its [__] job and that that
was just it I didn't have it for 2 days
I didn't have it for 3 days I just had
it for like 7 hours and my body so
aggressively got it the [__] out of me
um but then what I didn't realize was uh
you know I needed to eat like some Greek
yogurt or something like that I think I
just puked everything and [__]
everything [__] out of me I so or or
something I don't know I I this I know
this is disgust I was wretching so bad
like two days later the side of my neck
near my throat was killing me and I was
thinking like was I screaming in traffic
that I [__] my voice up and I was like
no that was from [__]
puking oh my god
dude there was a point in the bathroom
like if I started like levitating and
floating upside down above the toilet
like Trent resar in that 9in Nails
[__] video it wouldn't have surprised
me like that's like that's what like I
had no
control you know over the body and I and
I just [__] wrote it out but then the
next day I was like
fine and you know you know the next day
after you go hot tell you after you go
through one of those you know you got to
be real careful what you
pick
so my wife was going you want some like
uh that what what they some electrolytes
and blah I like I don't want to drink
that [__] that sugary [__] horrible
[__] I don't I don't want that she goes
what do you want I go I want a
cantaloupe I don't want the one one
that's pre-sliced I want you to buy one
okay from that [__] Health Food
[__] store down the
street and and and she's like we don't
have one in the fridge I go no we don't
I feel like I was pregnant I was like
specifically I want that so she ended up
getting me the thing and
uh I just slowly work my way back I
forget it took me like 2 days to get
back to being just able to eat but I got
to tell you this this is how [__] up
this businesses that I'm
in is at one point when I was
puking and just
like in the middle of that I actually
had the thought of my stomach's going to
look great
tomorrow my stomach's going to look flat
and it did I lost yeah I really didn't
lose weight it's fun some douche will
say actually it's just water way you
know you going to put it right back on
we drink glass water [__] off can I just
look good for half a morning
um so that was my weekend and then I
just kind of like laid around all day
Saturday like the whole [__] day
something I KN oh no no I
didn't wait a minute no I didn't I had
to [__] finish all of that
[__] because
uh some friends of mine were in
town uh oh God I almost I how do I tell
this [__] story this is another
another make a wish Bill Burr [__]
story how do I tell this one so long
story short you guys know I'm a big fan
of skid Ro right I'm always talking
about like how much I love that that
second album that I love the first one
you know and I went and I was going to
see
Aerosmith you know Boston guy I grew up
on [__] Aerosmith right so I'd
already seen Aerosmith on the Permanent
Vacation tour who opened for him on that
one I saw him at Reynolds Coliseum in
Raleigh North Carolina with Tesla opened
up and then the next album they that was
a big comeback album and then I saw
erros Smith on the pump tour in 1989
December 31st
1989 the end of
the80s I had been arrested for drinking
and driving I did not have a license I
had yet to be arraigned unbeknownst to
me you know the two weeks that I waited
to actually go in front of a judge and
all of that [__] [__] would not be
those those 14 days would not be applied
to the 45 days I got suspended license
this is the 80s you didn't get that many
days right so anyway I went there
without a license and Skid Row was
opening up and they this is when that
that album 18 in life Youth Gone Wild
and this amazing new front man Sebastian
Bach came out you
know new [__] Guitar Hero and Dave
snakes you know Sabo you know Jersey
guys and all of this stuff right I think
Sebastian was from Canada whatever so
they went out they [__] killed it and
this is when I was still like trying to
figure out what I wanted to do when I
knew I love playing drums I was thinking
like am I a musician I actually thought
that at some point in my life am I a
musician am I going to join a band like
that's all I did was I I listened to
Comedy and I watched all these metal
bands that's all I [__] did and I
watched [__] Rambo and Schwarz Ando
movies that was really was and I got
shitfaced and drove drunk that's what I
did that you know there wasn't a lot and
I [__] up in school and I worked in a
warehouse this is what that was my
[__] life and you know what it was
awesome it was [__] awesome I [__]
loved the80s I had a [__] great time
I had such a [__] great time and one
of the greatest things about it was the
[__] music right so over the years I
was talking about
how you know I missed the boat when
grunge first came in I was just too
[__] old for
really kind of came in I was 23 and 23
is really old just to catch on to a new
style of [__] it just is you're supposed
to be coming out of college I wasn't I
was working my way I had to pay pay my
way through college so I was working my
way through I missed the boat their
second album came out [__] monkey
business uh Slave to the Grind All That
I [__] loved it it was even heavier
than their first one and I'm like yeah
these [__] guys are these guys got ST
power I saw these guys this [__]
they're going to have a big headline in
tour I saw them when they open and all
that [__] blah blah blah blah and then
you know all of those [__] Seattle
bands came and then it was just like
what the [__] happened and also like
around that time I started doing
stand-up comedy and then I just stopped
going to to shows on Friday and Saturday
night because I was doing shows
well fast forward all these years later
you know
um I
uh
I don't know I don't where the [__] I
was I was I was hanging out and I get a
text
message from
uh this dude Billy roow who plays with
Buck Cherry and also has this these
great guitars he makes uh rock and roll
relics just a badass a guy that I did I
do the dean Del re Bon Scott thing with
him he text me a few months back said
hey you know it's snake's birthday he
loves your comedy you know we're out
here grinding up you know you want to
FaceTime and say happy birthday to him
right so I say you know I'm like holy
[__] I can't [__] believe I'm going
to talk to this guy so I FaceTime him
you know totally [__] cool guy I can
tell by his vibe that he's legit into my
comedy because I wasn't you know
sometimes people say that and then you
just meet him they're like who the [__]
are you and the other person just set
you up for just this weird thing and it
wasn't he was totally [__] cool you
know Jersey guy or whatever right East
Coast guy right so we hit it off and I
said yeah man I got to to see you guys
man I I haven't seen you guys in forever
since I started doing comedy so whatever
blah blah blah blah blah long story
short they playing the Fonda theater and
uh Billy text me again and said hey you
want to come down and sit in and play
drums during during their
soundcheck and I was just
like are you [__] me [__] yeah like
I didn't even look at my calendar it's
like whatever's on my calendar is
getting moved canceled or blown off
right
so I go down
there and
uh I got to meet Scotty Hill the two two
last original guys Scotty Hill and uh
and snake and they were [__] cool as
[__] and then all his other bandmates
that were there there's another guy
named Rob that plays drums he was cool
[__] great drummer too really smooth
anyway I get to sit
in and and uh you know we did Highway to
Hell it funny people asked me like did
you play Youth Gone Wild did you play I
was like dude you realize they've been
playing that song for 36 [__] years
like they don't want to
[__] they got to give that song they
all once a [__] night and they ain't
going to do it with some [__] [__]
joke comedian so we just did a a Highway
to Hell thing I played on these Pearl
Drums and uh the tension on the
uh the uh the pedals which were also
Pearl was was like like perfect it took
a second to get adjusted to it cuz it
wasn't like my kid but uh unfortunately
I just you know taking a lesson with
Dave elich and he was fix some stuff
that was going on with me that I didn't
like and uh we sat down we ran through
it and I can't even tell you how many
times I just the whole time we were
playing the song you know I'm listening
to everything it sounds great and
everything but like I kept drifting off
thinking about
me back in ' 89 being in the crowd
without a driver's
license and if you told me back then
that all right years
later you're going to get to jam and
play Highway to Hell your favorite band
of all time ACDC right with two of the
guys both guitar players from [__]
skid Road they're going to be cool as
[__] and you're going to be a standup
comedian I I I probably would have
fainted so it was an unbelievably cool
moment everybody in the band Buck Cherry
to they were like the coolest [__]
guys and uh as fun as jamming with them
was talking to them was was was was just
as big a [__] thrill and uh you know
they made me feel right at home they
made me feel like I did a good job or
whatever man it was just [__] it was
[__] awesome so
um that all happened in like like
[__]
um what is that like maybe 16 hours I
got sick at 6 o00 on Friday and at noon
on Saturday after Poltergeist coming out
of both ends of
me around probably I guess 1:00 the next
day I played [__] highway
elf I think it was really what brought
me out of it I was so [__]
giddy um
still can't believe that happened anyway
uh let's talk some NFL football I didn't
see too much today cuz uh my daughter
had a a birthday party uh it seemed like
there were a lot of upsets and I I might
have gone 0 and four this week like I
don't know what I just watched the first
half of the [__] Eagles and the
Cowboys man I mean as a football fan
it's exciting if the Cowboys win because
then they're tied with the Eagles but
Jesus
Christ you know what a wait if the
Eagles lose this [__] game too what
you guys already know what happens right
just put the [__] game on no I hate
when I do that I get too distracted on
the podcast sports fans like it if
you're into football whatever but I I
just feel like uh they can't lose this
[__] game man I mean it's just
obviously bill it's a stupid statement
this see this is why I I would never
[__] get into sports analogy whatever
the [__] it is I mean you just say
obvious [__] what I'm trying to say is
that like a couple of [__] weeks ago
if you were going to say the [__]
Eagles would going be in this situation
it's not only that they lose backto back
[__] games it's who they lose them to
which are basic who they lost to which
is basically to the top [__]
teams um I mean the Cowboys I don't you
know I don't know what the [__] they are
but they they're coming on the Eagles
seem like they're starting to nose dive
a little bit and then they got [__]
raped by the goddamn
49ers like I I did a standup show a few
weeks ago there was an Eagles fan in the
crowd and he was just convinced like
dude we are going to the [__] Super
Bowl and I was an arguing with him I'm
like I mean you got the quarterback you
got the offensive line you got the
weapons your defense looks great your
[__] coach is killing it and the
guy's that guy's
hilarious [__]
[Music]
Nikki did he yell at anybody this week I
mean I I mean I'm not going to get mad
at a guy that goes around and has
unnecessary arguments with people I mean
that's that's been 30% of my [__]
adult life I mean how [__] hilarious
was that watching him go out of the
cheap stadium and just yelling at the
fans that he gives he like gives a [__]
like a fan
um oh by the way underrated
Italians in the
NFL Tommy
cutlets this guy we need more to [__]
tomies and Nikki and bring those [__]
guys
back last great Italian I'm thinking in
the NFL was Franco
Harris uh remember Franco's Italian army
they used to have right um
anyway we shall see we shall see what
happens as the uh as the weeks go on but
uh and how about my [__] Patriots I
didn't even know they were playing
Thursday night I've been so goddamn busy
[__] pitching another idea out here
right and uh we [__] beat the
Steelers
again in
Pittsburgh with the weakest [__] team
we've had in forever I will say
death taxes and the patriots beating the
Steelers and death taxes and the
Patriots losing to the Giants we lose to
the Giants not only in the Super Bowl
pre-season regular season if we're if if
they're [__] you know we're both
[__] 2 and
10 you know we still [__] lose to him
I don't know what it is Tom Coughlin
there Tom Coughlin not [__] there I
don't know what it
is it's weird Giants have our number the
way the [__] uh we have the Steelers
number everybody's got that one [__]
team you know the dolphins dolphins
honorable mention during the Tom Brady
years always good for one one [__]
win a year always good for one year win
a year now they got that thing where you
know the way they built the
stadium you know they Ed global warming
they knew it was coming so they built
the stadium where their
[__] their team would be in the shade
the whole game and the other team would
just be baking in the [__]
Sun you know it's the little things it's
the little things now here's the thing
if the Dolphins had actually won a
[__] Super
Bowl you
know remember that undefeated season
they have yeah nobody does if you do
you you're about dead I mean that was
like
[__] forget about how many years ago
that was it was 51 years ago I believe
let's how many presents ago was that
sleep
Joe dumb
Donald
[__] Obi Obi-Wan CAD Dr
drony the boss's
son uh the guy used somebody's [__] as
a humidor that's
five uh The Aviator before him the
actor the humanitarian
Aran uh the [__] All-American
fullback and then sweaty lips right
that's 10 [__] presidents 10
presidents a go that doesn't make any
sense oh that's because he got impeached
Ford was only in there two years Carter
did one turn Bush did one
[Music]
term and Trump did one turn term and
then uh what's his forgetful Freddy here
is probably going to be a one one and
done
right which you tell me this [__] isn't
fixed I don't get how Biden beats Trump
four years ago and then somehow more
Trump people are going to come out like
like someone who voted for Joe Biden is
now going to vote for Trump that doesn't
[__] happen Nobody Does that
everybody's so [__] on their one side
that's it
right I don't know I I'm calling Vegas
on this one I have no idea but I
definitely
think
uh I don't know they should have left
him alone they should have left him
alone let sleeping narcissists lie
didn't they [__] learn anything the
first time if they didn't make fun of
him I I believe when he was at that
roast and they stuck him in the middle
of that [__] room and they humiliated
him they had no [__] idea that that
was one of the worst moments
in US history cuz he didn't even want to
be president until they [__] did that
to him and then he was like oh yeah
watch this and then he [__] did
it right and then he didn't know what
the [__] he was doing and then his
crowning achievement is he led [__]
200 of the dumbest [__] people I've
ever seen in my life to attack the wrong
building in DC but then he felt good The
Narcissist felt good people died people
went to jail all in the name of him and
all of that [__] and then he just would
have gone off into the [__] he pouted
when he lost you know he [__] cheated
and he just went away like some [__]
2-year-old and that would have been it
but instead they decided for whatever
[__] stupid reason to prosecute this
guy for something that all rich people
do all the [__] time it's it's like
yeah it's like the sign stealing [__]
all right we don't got anything on him
yeah get get him for sign stealing and
now he's back right
that's like when they do a sequel to a
movie that like you almost
forgot it's like they're remaking that
who like who who the [__] needs to see
that Howard the Duck part two you know
you guys old enough to remember that or
Leonard part 6 which was the first one I
actually watched that cuz I was such a
fan of Cosby and I sat there when I
first got cable and I watched that whole
movie expecting at some point for it to
get funny and I want to say the movie
ends with Bill Cosby riding an ostrich
down the
street like off into the sunset or
something like that like I I have
no I have no [__]
idea how you [__] a movie up that bad I
will say that like it was like what was
on the [__] page versus what the [__]
you shot and then what the [__] you
ended up with look oh look at me oh oh I
direct a couple things all of a sudden
yeah yeah you know what no
no it shouldn't been he rides a [__]
ostrich over the thing and you yeah
let's make
this but it was the80s I mean there was
a lot of coke being
done somebody probably questioned it
like why would you do that and because
it's never been
done anyway I am
uh still getting over a little bit of
this cold and it's funny I'm like living
a straight like a beyond straight edge
life right
now like uh I don't know what happened
to me with coffee like the idea of
drinking coffee now just like absolutely
disgusts me because I I didn't drink it
for two weeks and then I had a cup and
it was like okay and then I had one the
next day at like one of the places I
always go to and it was like gross like
I didn't like I just think I [__]
ODed on it like I do with every [__]
thing in my
life can't just have one bill right you
got to eat the whole [__] sleeve of
cookies right can't just have one
[__] drink you got to drink the whole
[__]
12pack you know you can't sit in a bar
like a [__] normal person you have to
drink them out in the woods around a
[__] bonfire right that's what you
got to do sorry got to blow my [__]
nose
um I don't know
so I'm kind of done with
cigars I'm going to try to do like this
thing where I I'm for the 9 millionth
time but I just don't think I can do it
be that guy that has like
discipline you know I've been able to do
it with like desserts I just said this
year I'm I'm not I don't [__] eat
desserts you know it's not my birthday I
yeah I don't need a [__] slice of
cake I don't need pie I don't need
donuts I don't need candy candy what am
I
[__] 6 years old this is
stupid I [__] hate going to the gym I
hate when I take my shirt off and I look
like like I you pulled me out of a
[__] Lake I'm sick of looking water
logged how many [__] M&M's you going
to eat bill you [__] fat freckled
[__] this is how I talk to myself I look
in the mirror and like my wife's
laying she just hears me in there like
yelling at
myself there you go
stupid look at that big white [__]
belly right
just hammering myself here oh am I
[__] talking too loud I think I'm
going up to the green
here um no I mean up to the yellow
almost into the red here
um I forget how to turn that [__] down
I'll figure it out next week next week
I'll do that so anyway
um I just decided cuz my tour does not
start back up again until February and I
am going to lose this last little bit
and I've been doing great I've been
going to Holiday I went to [__]
amazing amazing [__] holiday party
the other night last night the PCI I
don't want to say who the [__] it was
or anything like that I don't to get it
all I don't like naming names okay it's
not my style
um I [__] um I went there the dude
that hosted it I mean the guy had like a
[__] 100 piece Orchestra I swear to
God I what was that I was like I don't
know how many people it
was I mean to me that was the party just
watching that human beings still do that
like how
unbelievable these musicians were and
how they could all play together
and it didn't even sound
real it sounded like a recording they
were that good and they were just
playing all this unbelievable Christmas
music it was like there was a big band
surrounded by an entire string section
French horns [__] Kettle drums
somebody on a
harp
I mean it was basically they went into a
music store they bought all the
instruments and then had a [__] the
Wayne Gretzky of whatever on each one of
them they were unfuckingbelievable
um so we hung out there for a couple of
hours great food [__] awesome people
man it was just an a great time and then
I had a spot up the uh up The Comedy
Store and I went up there and uh you
know tried out some new [__] that I'm
working on and uh
for whatever reason I I was trying to
work like
cleaner you know cuz I thought for a
second I was going to be doing this TV
show you know so I was like well why
don't I I'm working on this new material
and it just seems like it's a quick it's
going to have a quick shelf life so I'm
like all right why don't you just write
it clean like you did 30 years ago and
just see how that
goes right and I started doing that I'm
going to try doing that like the the
next like 10 minutes I have I'm just
going to write it clean just so I have
that so if I get this gig I don't have
to [__] worry about you
know cuz for me always taking out the
curse
words everybody acts like it's harder
what it is it's it's it [__] with the
Rhythm unless what you're saying isn't
funny then you're screwed but if what
you're saying is funny when you take out
the curse word it [__] with the Rhythm
so all you have to do is is you know
just look at it like music you can't Lop
off an eighth note then it becomes like
odd time and odd
time it it it's not going to be funny
you know what I mean you want your [__]
in 44 for comedy so what you have to do
is just replace the curse word with the
with the same amount of syllable like
word like if it's like [__] you need
a two symbol two syllable cleaner Bill
we get it all right or there's also a
way you just pause or hit harder on a
different word which creates a pause and
and the line is still delivered in the
same amount of time you know what I mean
um almost like simplifying a Phill but
it's still over four beats if that makes
sense
so yeah that sounds like a [__] math
problem right I don't want to have to
deal with that [__] so
um and I also got a minut I kind of
liked it I kind of
liked you know it was just like a
different thing I do like just going up
there and just saying whatever I'm
thinking but that was the first time I
was like I haven't done this in a while
like trying to craft this in a in a way
that is different from the way I just
usually do [__] which is go up and talk
because sometimes I I watch people's
process
um like I that is fascinating to me how
different people put their [__] together
and and
um I don't have my process is no process
my process is just to go I'm talking
about that and then go up and talk about
it and then see how it
goes and then um not learn anything from
it and then do it again the next
[Music]
night that's almost how I handle all my
relationship I'm just babbling I'm just
goofing um all right let
[Music]
me let me what am I doing here
I got to read
uh I got to oh okay here we go we got to
do some advertising oh look who it is
everybody it's old
zip um talk about that one person on
your holiday list who's really hard to
find the perfect gift for examples my
best friend because they already have so
many things my husband my wife because
we've been together for so long my dad
because he's really
picky uh
um no it would be probably my wife cuz
i' i' I've bought her a lot of [__] we
have been all together for a long time I
I don't know what else to get her but
you know she's a woman so there's always
something
else I've been Jimmy the Gent for
Christmas and birthdays now for 10 years
don't [__] buy me anything take it
take it back take it back I don't
[__] want anything I would like take
me to the movies
there's a great Christmas gift take me
to the [__]
movies take me take take me to a [__]
thing
um something take me
just [__] leave me alone I mean I
don't
know I don't need
anything enough like how much [__] do
you want to have to throw out when I die
I mean this is stupid already all right
but if you're business business owner
and you need to grow your team your
perfect gift is simple you want a smart
hiring solution so look no further than
zip big
recruit zip recruiter everybody all
right and right now we're gifting it to
you for free at ziprecruiter.com bur how
is
zip recruiter a gift to those who are
hiring well I'll tell you zip recruiter
uses smart matching technology to
identify the most qualified people for a
wide range of roles
zip lets top candidates know when
they're a great match for your job to
encourage them to apply and the bow on
top well [__] if you see a candidate
who's a great match for your job zip
makes it easy to send them a personal
invite he's sliding their DMS hey
sweetheart think I got a cubicle with
your [__] name on on it so there's
more likely so they're more likely to
apply and just go to this exclusive web
address right now to try zip recruiter
for free ziprecruiter.com bur again that
zip
is.com bur spell out bir b r r z
recruiter the smartest way to hire I was
in my head on that one I tried too hard
oh OIC oh somebody's going to write
write it o oh o
OIC
losing that [__]
weight no that's not this what is what
what is what is a
real song that they
did oh oh oh oh
zic you know now that's supposed to be
for diabetics I believe and people are
using it to lose weight I'll tell you
right now if you want an all natural way
you want an all natural way to [__]
lose some weight get the stomach flu all
right
if no one in your family has it well
[__] go out and go get
it um hey uh Bill I'm just waiting for
the class action against OIC my wife was
on it for 3 four months before she had
to have her gallbladder
removed never had a had a problem with
her gallbladder in the
past oh my God that's terrifying yep and
I can tell you something right now
there's going to be nobody in this
election next year blue or red tie that
is going to call out the pharmaceutical
industry and the [__] that they've done
to people the [__] that they continue to
do how they've infiltrated the FDA to
[__] pass all their [__] through none
of them are going to talk about it they
had th000 Points of Light trickle down
[__] you know tax the rich [__]
[__] the poor get the foreigners out of
here build a [__] wall the education
we need to pay there they're going Dance
all around and they're not going to
bring any of that [__] up
okay but the candidate that they say is
a fringe candidate person will do it
um it's unreal it's un they just they
don't [__] go to jail they literally
kill people they they affect people's
[__] lives and just nothing [__]
happens to
him um if I'd learn anything you know
from My World Travel uh you're you're on
your own and it's
stupid
I think once we became just so many
[__] people that was maybe that was
inevitable I don't
know you think back when there was just
little tribes people would there was
still probably you know the Steve Jobs
caveman um anyway coming out with a new
club every
year oh sorry all right Jimmy Kimmel oh
yeah I had a great I I love that guy I
had such a great time when I show the
other night uh dear Bill great job on
Kimmel yes we have a great time busting
each other's
chops uh I see you get a lot of [__] for
a lot of stuff you say but if you dig
beneath the ginger Laden rage you've
made some great calls a look at me every
once in a while I think I made some
great calls this Sunday on these
football games as you have said on
Kimmel they should have shut the hell up
and let that guy go away yeah they
should have neutral energy people listen
this is a great time of year to learn
how to deal with a narcissist okay
you're going to go home for Christmas
you know maybe I don't know hopefully
you don't have one in your family uh if
you do if you
do um there's only one solution man you
just you got to you got to cut them out
of your life it's [__] unreal it's
hard but you you know I'll tell you what
the weirdest thing
is this is as you know it's actually
getting a narcissist out of your life is
really easy because what what you do is
you
just call
them and return their text you know or
initiate texting at the same level that
they do which is not like a narcissist
the phone works one way unless they want
something all right but generally
speaking as far as like hey man just
call to say what's up they never do that
you have to come to them so the bottom
line is if you [__] just start doing
that to them like I'm I'm going to wait
for them to call me your relationship
with them will be over within a 2 to 3
month period And I don't care how long
you've known them and they will F
slighted and they will feel like victims
and all that but who gives a [__] um
they're out of your life um but anyways
this person says if we have to end
endure another four years another four
years he might be back for another eight
years uh if we have to endure another
four years it won't be your fault but
somehow you'll probably get a little
blame
ha love you and love the podcast oh yeah
that was because the first
time when everyone was like freaking out
I was on con going like it's you know
it's not going to affect your life I was
talking to like you know the average
white guy out there it's not going to
affect your life and uh it
didn't um it didn't I mean you
know and the guy [__] burned himself
out and [__] the whole thing up and he
was done and then they just had to go
knock on his [__] door again I don't
don't know why they did
that especially when the guy there's
sticking in the ring I don't even know
if he's going to make it to next [__]
November
um how are these our only two [__]
choices Jesus [__] Christ and then
the other guys they're just [__]
weirdos it's just getting weirder and
weird you know what it is I I really
think it is because now like there's
just so many [__] [__] too on the
internet that are just did you see that
one where they're making fun of that guy
from Florida where the guy's doing the
voice over of of the dude's inner
thoughts going my name is so and so I am
a human person I have on a big boy suits
with my my man shoes or something like
that and it's just doing you could
basically do this to [__] anybody but
like no one as you're standing out there
they like this is like footage that
wasn't even going to be on TV and they
just [__] had it and then somebody
makes that video and if everyone's just
you're just just sitting on a [__]
dunking stool I just think anybody with
a brain is like I don't want that
[__]
job I don't want that
job I also do love that people are dumb
enough to think that a guy that makes
400 Grand a year is somehow going to
turn around this [__] country just
[__] blows my
mind you know what I mean you can you
can make more money a year showing your
clam on Instagram then you can't run in
this
country um you get paid more I should
say say I'm not talking about Kickbacks
all right that's where the president
beats out the average [__] on Instagram
and that's how you get the house on
[__] Epstein Island all right dear
billum the bashful uh this year's
Thanksgiving food was terrible oh that's
the worst I've had one of those I'm
sorry I ever tell you the time like me
and Nea did it we [__] had we decided
to have a
vegetarian Thanksgiving I know I know I
know listen we all have stuff that we're
ashamed of in our past that was the
dumbest [__]
idea like oh my God we beat ourselves up
about that I can't even remember what
the [__] we had but it all sucked now in
defense of vegetarians we didn't know
how to cook it properly but like if you
don't know how to [__] cook it
properly the first time you do it you
don't [__] do it on Thanksgiving and
that's what the [__] we did and it
sucked so [__]
bad that I went down to the Laugh
Factory to feed homeless people not
because I cared about them it was
because they used to have this Deli
green blats next door and you could buy
a Thanksgiving dinner and I went there
and I ate one and I was felt so guilty I
had turkey and gravy and mashed potatoes
and a piece of pie and I came
home and I just had to confess to my
wife that I did
that and she went she like laughed acted
like she was all betrayed and then the
next night I took her out um for
something like that it was the worst
[__] that was my worst year of
Thanksgiving and then one year I had a
great I had a great [__] Thanksgiving
with no great
food I was
[__] this chick had dump
me and I was single and I didn't give a
[__] and I remember just thinking like
you know
what I'm staying single
[__] this
[__] just [__] this [__] like what am I
doing I just gone from one relationship
to another I'm not [__] doing this
I'm just going to be [__] single and
there was another buddy of mine he was a
comedian and his him and his chick had
just broken up and we just decided that
we were going to sit in my apartment and
drink [__] beers and watch football
and get [__]
up and we were not going to have any
Thanksgiving and we weren't going to eat
any differently we were just we were
going to embrace the fact that we had no
one in our lives except for us and we
had the best [__] time and we were
just laughing talking about like I guess
we're supposed to be missing people
right now and we didn't we didn't miss
anybody and it was [__] amazing so i'
I've had two thanksgivings where the
food one where it sucked and then the
other one where we didn't even have any
and I didn't give a [__] so anyway so
here's this person story
um I'm a 29-year-old single guy with
three older sisters who are all married
with kids so I have one Thanksgiving to
go to this year my sister decided our
mother is too old to cook oh and they
all wanted to take care of the food huge
mistake all in capital letters no
cranberry sauce I mean you can just buy
that no green bean casserole all right
this is is a white dude all right I'm
feeling I'm feeling seen here no [__]
pumpkin pie another white
staple and to top it all off no
turkey bill they bought barbecue turkey
legs like at a goddamn Renaissance
Festival oh they didn't they just
[__] they postm it yeah that's your
Modern Woman they can't [__]
cook they they feel like they're above
it and if elected I tell all these
broads to get back in the kitchen um I'm
not saying that you should like you
should [__]
like have to cook all the time but you
should know how to as an adult you
should know how to [__]
cook that that's a big one man or woman
you got to like you got to man the
[__] Grill you got to know how to
throw down to to a to an acceptable
level you got you got to have a couple
of go-tos that you just know this is a
family recipe I can do this and I will
not embarrass myself I will not I will
not be a cancer in this [__] locker
room so any goes they bought like they
were Renaissance Festival what the [__]
was that [__] also they tried to make
this crunchy mac and cheese but it was
all breadcrumbs where where if I ate it
it would hurt the roof of my mouth yeah
they don't know how to
cook how the [__] did these women get
married are they making money are they
hot are your sister's heart something's
going on
here all right on top of all that before
I beforehand I asked if I could bring
any food and they just told me to bring
wine and beer so they were just like
don't worry we got this one of my
brother-in-laws only drinks sours so I
was told to make
sure I brought that a $20 four pack for
[__] sake if I invested all of this
the least they could do is make
semi-normal Thanksgiving food now I know
there's a lot of women going well why
didn't you [__] cook you know why cuz
they said they were going to all right
so shut your face this guy has every
right to [__] he said should I bring
food they said no we got it you just
bring the booze which he did he held up
his side of the [__] bargain all
right despite our mother's declining
Health she was insistent on making food
for Christmas and next year's
Thanksgiving Bill how do I tell them to
just keep it simple why do we have all
these Alternatives were they trying too
hard to show they can cook
no no I don't first of all don't ever
try to think why a woman did something
okay that doesn't make any sense okay
you'll be lucky if you can guess what
the average guy is thinking it's another
human being and then when you're talking
about a woman as a man it's a different
[__] species all right you have no
[__] idea what they're thinking all
they did was show you that they can not
cook on any [__] level and they are
years away from getting good at it years
away from being the captain of the ship
on a Thanksgiving all right so what you
need to do is uh I I just wouldn't go or
what I would do next
year is like I would have a backup
Thanksgiving I would have a Thanksgiving
that I go to before their Thanksgiving
and what I would do is show
up you know to their Thanksgiving and
just drink beer and when they ask why
you're not eating just say you're
getting a colonoscopy the next day and
they're going to be like aren't you not
supposed to be drinking booze and no
it's just
food or you just be like well I mean I
got to do something on Thanksgiving
right I'm only having a couple I would
just do that or you could
just you could just do the easiest thing
just tell the truth just be like listen
that was some of the worst Food I've
ever had in my life I love you guys
you're my sisters but you
know
if you cooked for me every night like I
wouldn't love you
anymore all right happy
holidays this really isn't a hard one
dude I get it you want to see your
mother or whatever but she said that
she's cooking next Thanksgiving
um what a what a thing to do to your
mother she must be thinking like where
did I go wrong that I didn't teach these
Brads how to [__] cook you know you
got of you got to be a little I know
your mom's sick but you
know you know you know it starts at the
top right the head coach is the first
one that gets fired no um anyway car
ownership dear Billy the wise ass oh
dear Billy the wise parenthesis ass a
small group of people uh bash electric
vehicles and the stupid videos they make
work cuz they annoy easy targets like
you um all
right sales are up and charging stations
are popping up everywhere they're not
going away a couple people trashed the
internet when it came around were you
one of them
LOL well yeah but part of me is also to
tell jokes and [__] laugh at
[__] all right I mean what am I supposed
to do I'm supposed to be like I mean you
think I don't know that electric cars
are coming and that they're here to stay
I think once Porsha has thrown their
[__] hat the the the ring I really
don't think you're giving me any new
information all all right you smarmy
[__] okay the real problem isn't the
cars you know what I this person here is
is [__] more annoying probably than
the food that those women made all right
the real problem isn't the cars it's
laws in forcing people to switch to them
which states are now planning for all
new car sales this bothers people
because it makes us it makes it Us
Versus Them the wave of effects it's
going to have in California on the
lowest income is going to be
catastrophic as opposed to
what as opposed to what everything is
going to be catastrophic to the lowest
income everything is catastrophic to the
middle class at this point everything is
so like I I don't know what like this is
the thing that's going to take out poor
people they're already [__] I could
argue the other side remember flat
screens first came out they were like
[__]
$113,000 now you can get one for a
couple hundred
bucks new technology is over always way
overpriced because the [__] uh you
know I got to I got to have it first
guys that's why I saw that that [__]
what is that that stupid [__] car the
um oh what is it called the [__]
Lucent it's a four-door sedan they want
250 grand for it it's [__] ridiculous
it's as ridiculous as a $113,000 flat
screen TV I are they going to come down
just like rollerblades did rollerblades
were 100 something bucks and then
everybody [__] had one and all of a
sudden they were
$30 um anyway and completely tighten
their ability to work and
travel um no considerations have or
likely will be made for this all right
so like just out of curiosity what do
the gas companies do to [__] help
these people oil companies have given a
[__] about low-income people
um there's there's just going to be rich
people and poor people that's where it's
going to go and you can't just blame
electric cars I think it's going to be a
whole bunch of things and it all goes in
the same [__] Direction
no um also there's lots of videos of
unelected officials saying Private Car
ownership is going to be obsolete in 15
years you can watch their videos where
they brag about it and these are the
people who put money behind politicians
so you know they can pull it off not
saying they will but the state clear uh
but they State clearly that they're
trying so don't call me
crazy happy holidays to you and your
family back e dude I'm not saying you're
crazy you're [__] talking about what
I'm talking about and then saying it to
me like it's it's the new just start it
off bad dude you just started off bad
like you don't watch anything and get
triggered on online all right um
anyway I had a meltdown today it's just
like at what point are they going to
feel like they're in control of us and
what are they planning I think it all
goes to the AI [__] I think all of this
AI stuff they know what they're working
towards and they know that once we
realize what it is they're actually up
to they want to have our ability you
know they're going to like they like I
don't know what it is they're just
attacking every [__] Freedom that is
out there and then you have these mouth
breathing morons that are into politics
and all they do is blame the other party
and you know and these newspapers that
go after stand-up comedians and actors
or whatever the latest person [__]
said and they're just completely
ignoring like why isn't the fact that
that insider trading [__] that senators
and Congress people do why isn't that
like something that is just talked about
every day like they did with [__] Co
why why aren't they doing that how come
these people are allowed to do
that and be worth $20 million just doing
something that why they decided that
what is illegal for us is not illegal
for them it's one of the most corrupt
overtly corrupt things that it's just
sort of known people like yeah I know
it's crazy it's crazy but then like you
you
know like if if there's some sort of
celebrity scandal with like an athlete
or whatever like that's like you know or
like are these baseball players doing
steroids did Lance Armstrong cheat in a
bicycle race like the [__] government
is like we're going to get down to the
[__] brass tax on this
um I just my question I just don't
understand why why are they just so why
why why are they so upset with people
being able to kind of drive
around and kind of do what they want to
do why are they like like these people
are sick unless they they they know
something that we
don't hey you know speaking of
Thanksgiving I mean maybe we're the
[__] turkeys about to get slaughtered
I have no [__] idea I didn't want to
end the podcast like that but I can tell
you right now that [__] is GNA [__]
happen
if we continue to just look at each
other is you're either a liberal or
you're a [__] conservative I feel
like we're playing like right into their
hands and we're going to lose um I don't
know but I don't have any solutions how
do you get
[__] 6.9 billion people all on the
same
page how the [__] do you do that who
knows I just take soless in the fact
that you know those [__] AI robots
eventually are going to going to [__]
kill
him oh the weather outside is frightful
all right that was a [__] dark way in
people listen there's enough darkness in
the world please don't send me [__] like
this cuz I just bummed you out and now I
have to go to [__] bed with this [__]
on my [__] mind
um you
know I don't know this is like the type
of thing where it's just like oh yeah I
I get why people buy guns when when you
when you start going down that thing he
like I get it I get it I mean you're not
going to win but at least you could take
a few out with you but who are you going
to kill you're not going to you're not
going to kill the right guys you're just
going to P the kill the [__] guys
that are sent out by the guys you want
to kill to come up and get
you that's what kills me is it's a bunch
of Suits the [__]
[__] um anyway all right that's it
okay I don't I don't how to end this
listen try to live in the
moment
sorry I have no out this is like when I
can't find a laugh to get off stage it's
just like all right that's my time good
night everybody um have a great couple
of days and I'll check in on you in a
couple of days go [__] yourself see
you